[Musique]
deux partitions anciennes thierry
malandain proposé écriture
chorégraphique nouvelle nocturne du fait
penser aux danses macabres moyenâgeuse
et choisi de travailler sur les lignes
ses danseurs évoluent sur un tapis de 2
mètres en espace contraint qui amuse le
créateur nicolas les nocturnes de chopin
c'est des musiques connues donc ça
permet au public de être à la fois au
niveau de l'oreille en terrain familier
et puis voir des images différentes
j'ai toujours aimé chopin ce qui se
passe c'est que l'ordinaire de la
compagnie cesse et des pièces de
commande souvent des oeuvres d'une
soirée et autres quand je peux pas je
m'attache à des musiques que j'aime et
chopin j'aime depuis toujours et je
n'avais jamais eu l'occasion de faire
quoi que ce soit le chorégraphe français
proposé à saint quentin en yvelines deux
créations dans un néo classicisme qui le
caractérise et qu'il revendique au
romantisme de chopin bistrot répond de
manière joyeuse
[Musique]
à
l'ambiance est et et joyeuse mais nous
manque en même temps là il ya un appel
plus spirituel même que la joie et aussi
est éphémère et j'y arrive au moment où
il faut passer de ce côté puis la
musique de vivaldi elle appelle à la
dynamique enfin c'est une balle et un
peu plus virtuoses au niveau des
ensembles un retour dans une
agglomération que thierry malandain
connais bien en 1986 il fonde sa
compagnie à elancourt avant de partir
pour saint-etienne puis biarritz la
compagnie revient dans les yvelines en
juin prochain pour quatre
représentations à l'opéra royal de
versailles
[Musique]